if you have it get two t-shirts right
and one smaller ones Lodge you like that
one's too small and this was too large
man what she would want is a size in
between what would you call that size
between okay small medium large if you
had two angry people nice people and
amusing
if you had two angry individuals and you
need to put someone in the middle to
kind of sort out their argument I think
Kathy on this one right
what would a person be called actually a
very specific name a person in between
[Music]
your scoring something you're squaring
something and describing its quality and
it was not a terrible no wonder for
those kind of somewhere tomato India
what might you if it was people look at
video God have you heard that word
before and it's not it's not great this
one
oh well I just I just didn't even say
meaning so in between these two enormous
land masses Europe and Africa long term
we have to see in school that thank you
as ministration C okay so what are you
support what the thing is right if you
have a served oddly and you wanted
something in the middle
unsurprisingly like what would what I
said medium mediate a video video not
many people Mediterranean Armenian just
made literally in in-betweens
in the middle between all of these
things no it's thank you okay now by the
way this is a really important because
you are just few words say okay what do
they have to do with anything like they
actually aren't attached to all of these
other ideas
it's that same language that we meant
now I would like you to I ask you get
your laptop's up so I'd like you to turn
to some of us it's we're going to
illustrate how to use these tools to
find the median and then we actually
come back to 7/3 for to actually do some
tasks in there but it just America okay
so this is what you should see right at
the top of 706 and you've already seen a
few times that when you can visualize
something
the two we can look at later when you
can visualize daughter is it's really
helpful if folks can understand what's
going on which is very useful so here is
a bunch of dots which is well how many
holders have not one very original and
each one of these dots represents an
individual or school and you can see the
scores that they have down the bottom
here and we don't know what these seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve is maybe
they're like you know scores or marks
added in a test thread and you've got
adult for each one we can use this to
work out whether so at first thing do
you remember if the media sitting in the
middle right what I would do is and we
have very very deterministic we could
cross up schools from the bottom and
from the top and we cross them off until
we arrive in the center in the middle so
for example I could cross up one score
at the bottom and I would mention to one
school cross cross cross cross cross
cross and how look at how many I've got
five on each sides you agree it's 550
and it's five pieces destroy right here
so now our value 10 will be immediately
in this case okay so you can go through
this process of crossing out or
alternatively have a look at how many
dots there are how many dots on it there
are 11 in total right so which of the
scores can we go straight to rather do
all of the cross well we should the
scores if we were counting up from the
bottom should be the middle one out of
11 from it should be deceased one right
because you will have five below and
find them up just like we demonstrated
with the crossing so if I cut up now I
could go one two three four five and
then six and
and before we talk about the other
things couple of another line and see
but you didn't say technique let's not
do the cross see let's see we can
calculate this one how many do you see
15 so if you think about 15 you might
like to find yourself in your books
might be useful to write this right if
you were dividing out 15 scores so that
there was a halfway point so there was a
halfway point do you read me how earlier
when you found five on one side five of
the other side of it one right in the
middle
how many sure I have an outside in this
case in care 37 just seven makes sense
five sides out there but I've said it on
one side and similarly other I've got
exactly one then third one which is the
one in the middle your grade seven plus
one plus seven so now how can we cut up
if I want seven on one side and the
actual so I'm looking for a scorn of age
that's let's count one two three four
five six seven eight
here the middle so do you greet 22
should be the median and you can go
ahead if you check this by posting off
as well can I ask you to have a look at
Patsy
this has more schools than the
previously cannot you wait this one
after yourself and if you think you know
it is to tell stories I just want to get
a sense when you're ready you're gonna
come here up and once I work out so
you've got an idea the weights to get
that's okay what else you get
[Music]
anyone else think they've got three
hands up okay so before we test your
hypothesis thank you to do high scores
did you count or 24 scores now this is a
bit thick isn't it because there isn't
just one mil score is there when you've
got an even number right
so in fact there's gonna be two in the
middle do you agree with that too in the
middle which two are the two tall ones
12 and 13 so let's think about this
right if I had 11 scores on one side and
letting scores on the other to number 12
will be here here's one score and number
13 will be the next one over one scores
eleven plus one plus one plus 11 does
that equal account for all the
propellant so it's really one right in
the middle here between the two between
score 12 and score 13 when you cap it up
where we've scored 12 this quantity were
they both in that's kind of nice for our
system so we wanted the average between
these two but if they both happen to be
37 then the median will also be I think
you get the idea now so I will let you
do team on your own but you might notice
there's a few other things that are
being asked for here I sit straight over
3 because that's we were talking about
the mode you just read this off right
the mode is the most comment that's all
the most frequent so let's come right at
the top when you have a look at player
you can just read this off a dock or
country which one is it just the 11 it's
just the highest ones I think you
saying all the others now last one I
want to talk about really briefly is the
range now we talked about this that not
in much detail man how would you divide
the letter biggest to minors and
swallows very good there's the biggest
one and I'm going to subtract the
smallest one Thurmond was at seven am I
getting food that in the calculation
lose your shake you heading why not oh
well there's no frequency of seven so
yeah very good not imminent look people
have like suppose this is scores on a
test
no people score seven or as far as I can
tell six or eight did you have
permission or sedition just like the IRA
really shows that it goes on forever yes
so we just chose to stop at 12 but it
could be like a million so we wouldn't
do a million by this very good so this
area does it okay it might be more
scores down yeah but we are only showing
this pattern here and we're leaving off
the million score because this I guess
is what's relevant this is where all
about people or as scores records in
okay so with the original is a twelve
take away hey Nate which is very good
good the ball away party a look at this
one you gotta pay close attention to
where your numbers down the bottom are
so hunk your top leave your bottom
what would the range being with this
you're entering fantastic one more time
take away our